Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Three, Episode Three: who delivers the welfare society's services.
Who actually provides all this welfare?
The welfare society makes a long list of benefits available to citizens.
It is common to say that the public sector carries out two different kinds of welfare tasks.
First, the public sector helps citizens who find it difficult to manage on their own and therefore need financial help.
About one third of the total public expenditure goes to cash benefits, transfer incomes, to citizens.
They are typically given to people without work and include, among other things, the old-age pension, early retirement pension, the state educational support, SU, maternity benefit, the child and youth benefit, unemployment benefit and sickness benefit, and cash benefit.
But for example families with children also get cash benefits, the child and youth benefit, which is justified by their having greater expenses than families without children or young people at home.
Second, the public sector provides a number of public service benefits to all citizens who need them.
This concerns, for example, nurseries and kindergartens, hospitals, elderly care and many forms of education.
The Folketing and the government lay down the framework for the Danish welfare society through legislation.
But it is especially the 98 municipalities that fill out the framework of the law.
It is the municipalities that in practice deliver most welfare benefits to citizens.
In addition come the regions, which are responsible for running most of the health service.
The regions run the hospitals, sygehusene.
They do not run the police, which is a state task, and not the nurseries, which are a municipal task.
The municipalities act as citizens' main entrance to the public sector.
The municipalities have by far the most of the tasks that are close to the individual citizen.
That applies, among other things, to: childcare in nurseries and kindergartens.
The folkeskoler, the public primary and lower secondary schools.
Elderly care.
Libraries and several other cultural tasks.
The effort to get the unemployed into employment, through the municipal jobcentres, which help unemployed citizens get back to work.
Integration of refugees and immigrants.
Allocation of a long list of social benefits.
And waste collection and other environmental tasks.
The state solves a number of overall tasks such as, for example, the police, the judiciary, that is the courts, domstolene, and defence, as well as tasks such as upper secondary education, gymnasiums and so on, higher education and research.
In connection with the structural reform in 2007, the state also took over all tax collection from the municipalities.
In Denmark, the welfare society is thus as a starting point a public task, carried out by the state, the regions and the municipalities.
But there are others involved as well.
Through the last decades it has become more common to let private companies carry out some of the welfare tasks, however in such a way that it is still the public sector that pays.
This is called outsourcing, udlicitering.
In elderly care, the individual can for example freely choose whether they wish to have home help delivered by the municipality or by a private provider.
There is also a strong Danish tradition of involving volunteers in solving welfare tasks.
As the name implies, they make an effort without being paid for it.
Associations and voluntary work are far more widespread in the Nordic countries than in almost all other countries.
There are many voluntary organisations.
They run, among other things, crisis centres, visiting schemes for the elderly, contact and drop-in centres and much more.
It is normally the basic idea that voluntary work should be a supplement to the public service and not a replacement.
It is thus still quite rare for voluntary organisations to be responsible for the basic service.
Voluntary organisations also play a very big role in cultural and leisure life.
That applies not least to sport, where thousands of volunteers act as coaches, for example for children who play football, handball or other sports.
Denmark also has a tradition of so-called free schools, friskoler, which goes all the way back to the middle of the 1800s.
The free schools are owned by an association behind the school, and not by the municipality, and are therefore also often called private schools.
They get a grant from the municipality which corresponds to a high share of the normal expense for a municipal folkeskole.
A smaller part is paid by the parents.
Free schools are found all over the country, and some are very old.
In Denmark, most are run on the basis of a particular educational idea or a wish to have a local school.
Most children still go to municipal folkeskoler, but in recent years there has been a big increase in the share of children who go to free schools or private schools: from about 14 percent in the school year 2008 to 09, to 20 percent in the school year 2024 to 25.
Involvement of parents is also central in Danish schools, kindergartens and nurseries.
For example, there are boards elected by the parents.
There are lots of parent meetings and activities where it is expected that all parents take part.
And in practically all classes, so-called contact parents, kontaktforældre, are elected to organise meetings and get-togethers, and to function as contact to the school board.
This usually goes in turns, so that most parents take part for a period.
Last but not least, the public welfare benefits are supplemented by agreements, collective agreements, overenskomster, between the parties of the labour market, trade unions and employers' organisations.
This applies, for example, to the pension area, where almost everyone today has a so-called labour market pension, arbejdsmarkedspension, which they pay into with a certain percentage of their wage, typically 12 to 17 percent.
The labour market pension is built on top of the old-age pension.
Where the old-age pension is meant to secure all citizens', especially the weakest's, basic needs in old age, the labour market pensions depend on the individual's income as economically active.
For many people with middle incomes or higher incomes, the labour market pension they get paid out is considerably higher than the old-age pension.
In addition to pension, these pension schemes also typically give support in critical illness, and insurance in case of illness and death.
Although not all employees are covered by a collective agreement, it has become the norm for the vast majority of jobs that they have a pension scheme.
Finally, there is also a big private market for pensions, where the individual can save up for their pension in a bank or an insurance company.
Here is your recap for Episode Three.
Public welfare tasks are of two kinds: cash benefits and services.
About one third of public expenditure goes to cash benefits.
The 98 municipalities deliver most welfare services, such as childcare, folkeskoler, elderly care, libraries, getting the unemployed into work, and integration.
The regions run most of the health service, including the hospitals.
The state handles police, the judiciary, defence, upper secondary and higher education, research, and, since the 2007 reform, all tax collection.
Outsourcing is called udlicitering.
Voluntary work supplements, rather than replaces, public service.
Free schools go back to the mid-1800s, and the share of children in free or private schools rose from about 14 percent in 2008 to 09 to 20 percent in 2024 to 25.
A labour market pension is typically 12 to 17 percent of wages and comes on top of the old-age pension.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What are the regions responsible for running?
Option A: The police.
Option B: Hospitals, sygehuse.
Option C: Kindergartens.
[DA] Hvad har regionerne ansvaret for at drive?  A: Politi  |  B: Sygehuse  |  C: Børnehaver
The answer is B: Hospitals, sygehuse.
It appeared in the June 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Sygehuse
Question 2.
Who has the main responsibility for running the hospitals?
Option A: The state.
Option B: The regions.
Option C: The municipalities.
[DA] Hvem har hovedansvaret for driften af sygehusene?  A: Staten  |  B: Regionerne  |  C: Kommunerne
The answer is B: The regions.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Regionerne
Question 3.
Who is responsible for running the jobcentres?
Option A: The municipalities.
Option B: The regions.
Option C: The state.
[DA] Hvem har ansvaret for driften af jobcentrene?  A: Kommunerne  |  B: Regionerne  |  C: Staten
The answer is A: The municipalities.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Kommunerne
Question 4.
Which of the following areas is the state responsible for running?
Option A: The police.
Option B: Kindergartens.
Option C: Hospitals.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende områder har staten ansvaret for driften af?  A: Politiet  |  B: Børnehaver  |  C: Sygehuse
The answer is A: The police.
It appeared in the November 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Politiet
Question 5.
Which of the following areas is the state responsible for running?
Option A: Courts.
Option B: Folkeskoler.
Option C: Hospitals.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende områder har staten ansvaret for driften af?  A: Domstole  |  B: Folkeskoler  |  C: Sygehuse
The answer is A: Courts.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Domstole
Question 6.
Which of the following areas are the municipalities responsible for running?
Option A: Courts.
Option B: Nurseries.
Option C: Hospitals.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende områder har kommunerne ansvaret for driften af?  A: Domstole  |  B: Vuggestuer  |  C: Sygehuse
The answer is B: Nurseries.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Vuggestuer
Question 7.
Which of the following areas are the municipalities responsible for running?
Option A: The folkeskoler.
Option B: The courts.
Option C: The hospitals.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende områder har kommunerne ansvaret for at drive?  A: Folkeskolerne  |  B: Domstolene  |  C: Sygehusene
The answer is A: The folkeskoler.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Folkeskolerne
That's the end of this part.
Well done.